i became completely obsessed with them
when i was seven
i have no idea why i'm i'm fairly
obsessive person
and so all of my spare time
as a teenager was spent sitting in my
blind
taking mostly in fact almost all useless
photographs of kingfishing
what if your superpower was that you
could watch an animal for
hours on end you'd never get bored in
fact
the longer you watched the greater your
concentration became
that's what happened to national
geographic photographer charlie hamilton
james
they dive into the water and catch fish
but you know britain is a
fairly drab place most of the time it
has a drab selection of
birds i mean there's some wonderful
birds i'm not one of the little
but um the kingfish is like a tropical
bird because it's so
bright and stunning kingfishers
these bright blue birds change color in
the light
from an iridescent blue to a glistening
green
it's actually not blue in the sense that
there is no blue pigment in birds
it's the way their feathers are
structured and the oils in them which
reflects blue light and absorbs other
waves oh really
yeah so kingfishers aren't at you know
they're they're not pigmented blue
so they're an almost electric blue so
they go from
you know from black to green to
turquoise to navy depending on how the
light's hitting them
and charlie could watch them from a
riverbank in bristol england
until the rest of the world seemed to
evaporate
he could watch them until he started to
see the world through their eyes
as a teenager charlie got so good at
capturing images of these kingfishers
that people started noticing
by the time i was 14 15 the bbc
you know down the road knew about this
kid who
could work with kingfishers and because
they're so bright and colorful
in the uk we love them we want them on
tv all the time
and i very quickly became the go-to guy
for kingfishers so
you're the bbc's go-to guy and you're 14
years old
like i mean that's pretty yeah between
sort of 14 and 16 it grew
but little did the bbc know that they
had a teenage delinquent on their hands
in fact instead of going to school
charlie was playing hooky just to film
these kingfishers
i can't concentrate on anything i'm not
interested in
school to me was a horrific experience
and i hated every minute of it and
my mom wasn't that bothered so she kind
of
enabled me in that sense and i knew what
i wanted to do
i wanted to film animals and take photos
of animals i didn't
need to go to school to do that i knew
that
um and i'd you know i was doing it
and years later charlie is still doing
it
but how did a teenage photographer go
from playing hooky to taking pictures
all over the world
peter gwyn and this is overheard at
national geographic
a show where we eavesdrop on the wild
conversations we have here at natgeo
and follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
this week i sit down to talk with
photographer charlie hamilton james
he talks about his unlikely journey and
the kingfishers
otters and vultures he's encountered
along the way
[Music]
more after this
when i was in my teens i wanted to be a
wildlife photographer and i remember
going to the
of this annual competition this global
competition called the wildlife
photographer of the year
and meeting the other british wildlife
photographers there
and realizing that none of them had any
money
so i decided that actually i don't want
to
do that i want to do something where i
can actually earn a decent living right
so i
transitioned my photography to wanting
to to work as a wildlife cameraman
at the bbc right so you know by by my
mid-teens i'd kind of
kind of had geographic magazines this
dream but in
the immediate in the short term i wanted
to get into tv just because it was a
more
consistent way of making a living right
so when i was 14 i was working
the guy that created planet earth
alastair father girl was a researcher
back then
and alastair gave me you know my first
jobs and then when i was 16 i got my
first job working on the david
attenborough series it was
it was called the trials of life right
david david edinburgh as you call him
and so that was my first sort of real
assisting a cameraman to get these
shots of kingfishers these slow motion
shots of kingfishers diving into the
water which
everyone seemed to love on tv so you go
from being this sort of you know
precocious gifted
teenager you were just doing kingfishers
and then you
and then what was your next thing otters
you keep doing these american
don't don't do your american i love it
when americans try and say artists
because they say otto's no
no no otters so um i
when i was 16 i became equally obsessed
with otters
and i saved up my money and i applied
for a grant from
my school a bursary from my school that
i'd left in such disgrace because i
think they had master
kind of a soft spot for this kid who
just i just couldn't play by the i hated
authority i couldn't play by the rules
but i think he's
he had a kind of soft spot for me so
they gave me i think gave me 500 pounds
of a travel bursary
and so i combine that with a load of
money i'd earn and a couple hundred
pounds my mum gave me and i went off
to the shetland islands which had far
the furthest most point of the uk
basically way up there
um in the north sea this little
archipelago and
i spent six weeks walking the beaches
photographing otters
because i had become obsessed with
artists so
wow so like the kid who doesn't want to
go to school
gets money from the school to go
shopping that's pretty that's a pretty
ingenious plan you've worked out there
it was it was i was very lucky
i understand my privilege as a result
but i was very lucky because
i chose otters and kingfishers and they
were the two
probably for all the animals filmed in
the uk
those were the two animals probably in
the highest demand they were very
difficult
both of them otters are really difficult
to film
you know and i remember in my mid 30s i
spent an entire year
just working on kingfish as an artist
like half your life later still being
there were other years when i didn't but
i remember
you know right just doing kingfishers or
not it was just relentless kingfishers
and artists so
i was really lucky that i chose those
two subjects to get obsessed with
we'll be back with more charlie hamilton
james after this
so what was your first assignment at
geographic this was
actually a major turning point in my
career because
i got this film commissioned by the bbc
i went off to start making and they said
oh we want this kind of cute funny film
about vultures
and i got out to kenya and tanzania and
realized that you know vultures are
in catastrophic decline across the
certainly
um africa and asia and
you know i i really struggled to make a
quirky funny film about
you know the fastest declining family of
species in history it's not
it's hilarious yeah so we made this film
and i
sat there editing him and the executive
producer and i ended up just banging our
heads against each other because i
wanted to make a conservation film
he wanted a wildlife film and in the end
he said you can have five minutes of
conservation in it
and i thought that was wrong
like fundamentally wrong and in the end
i got 15 minutes
conservation in it so it was a
compromise and you know i look back and
okay well fair enough he was probably
right to an extent because who wants to
be depressed and watch
sunday night tv and be depressed for an
hour and no one does
anyway so geographic came to me at the
time and
i remember having a conversation with my
editor for the story who was ken geiger
and he phoned me up and
he said hey we're going to do a kind of
quirky funny story
oh okay so i gave him my pitch which is
very
passionate you know pitch about what
amazing
uh struggle he's been this catastrophe
that was going on
and he turns around he said oh my god
this is we should do
you know a big geopolitical story on
this and i said i want to work for these
people
i want to work for people who are going
to take on
and i don't want to diminish the bbc
they're amazing but i just at that point
thought you know i want to work for
people
who are going to tell stories like this
because
these stories need telling so what was
what was it about
vultures you know because you have you
know you stated you have this notorious
you know short attention span for things
you're not interested in so
what did you find about vultures that
kept you focused
i love anti-heroes i made a film on
hyenas many years ago
for the bbc and and then i pitched
vultures because
people overlook hyenas people overlook
vultures so if you want to get something
commissioned they're perfect
they're very charismatic even though
they're disgusting and ugly
but they are charismatic and they're as
a result inherently interesting what do
you mean charismatic
how are they charismatic well scared
have you ever heard of a thick knee
no this is the little plover that
wanders around on the plains of africa
okay but you've heard of a vulture yeah
yeah because the thickness got no
charisma and the vulture's got charisma
you're right awesome look at that bird
it's amazing
god damn it's ugly yeah so they have
this kind of
anti-charisma let's say okay right my
job is to convince an audience that
actually
look past the ugliness these are
incredible
you know machines based these amazing
animals look at them
and that's a it's a really lovely
thing to be able to do is to turn the
tables on someone's
received narrative on something right so
did you have to come up with any sort of
like
duct tape inventions to to get vultures
yeah absolutely um i mean the
the key shot was this kind of inside the
carcass shot
if you can keep the frenzy going because
when vultures eat they it's a very slow
process until they frenzy
and the moment they frenzy they're what
does that mean instance they are going
absolutely crazy you know you got 50
vultures
having a crazed fight over a carcass
if you can drive in drop your camera and
get out fast enough
they come back in and carry on for it
and then they don't notice the camera
wow wow
but if you if you leave it two seconds
too long
one volt has to stop and then the whole
lot stop and that's it it's all over
no one's going in so there's this whole
timing kind of all there
yeah it's just crazy like this oh but
the eventual shot was it was a really
cool shot
and again it tells you know as i was
talking about what does it look like
what does it look like
it's this big it's like it's in a zebra
rib rib cage
and it's a big foot of a vulture and a
head coming in and then all the way back
it's got these different layers of
voltages in the background and you can
see the sort of black and white of the
zebra skin and you know
you can see the planes in the background
so you know you've got a story in one
shot
yeah and you've got an immersive
experience for the reader
to open the magazine and wow you've got
this kind of
what it's like to be inside that carcass
with them
so let me ask you about um
you have a son fred um how is he now
he's like 19.
he's 19. wow when i think we first met
it was right around the time that fred
had been diagnosed
with a medical condition can you talk
about that a little bit yeah i might cry
but i'll talk about it
the whole purpose of the whole process
of this interview is to make you
all right so okay i'll tell you but i
know i'm
but i'm not kidding in the sense that
it's an important event in your life
yeah it's the important event in my life
i think but it's also an incredible
story and i'll tell you the story
because it i it still blows me away
so fred's one day he's looking at his
phone
he keeps moaning about headaches he
keeps moaning he's tired he's always
asleep and when i was just a teenager
you know he's
16 he's of course he's lazy and tired i
was at that age
and he's looking at his phone very
closely all the time i think i wonder if
he's
you know needs his eye test so i take
him into town for an eye test and
the optician comes and gets me no this
is odd he pulls me aside and says
has he got lyme's disease i don't know
and he pulls up a picture of his optic
nerves and he's
he's got impacted optic nerves you know
that they're swollen on both sides
and we're looking at it and he's and i
i grew up in a medical family so i'm
like that can't be a brain tumor because
it's bilateral
normally if you have a brain tumor you
just get one optic nerve swollen but
this was two and i'm like
anyways look get them checked out so the
next day my wife takes them off to the
specialist
and this guy says this kid needs a mri
now
they air left him to salt lake he goes
off with his mum i drive down
they take the thing out the next day so
it is a tumor then
oh sorry yes it's a massive well it's
not matt it's the size of a peach
brain tumor in his right frontal cortex
wow
um and you know on the scan it's just
it's just so
it's this massive great blob in his head
so
for about four years fred's been asking
me if he can become a falconer
falconer and i'm saying no because i'm a
miserable old git as we've said
no we move everywhere life's too
complicated
you're not having a falcon he's over
he's just relentless and
after a couple of years you think all
right this isn't just a fad the kid is
genuinely
he had read every single book he was
obsessed with falconry and i recognized
that obsession
but i couldn't facilitate it because i
was
i guess probably being selfish anyway he
goes in he has this brain tumor taken
out they take the whole
side of his head off he's got his
beautiful blonde hair and they you know
they shave this
thing they just take the side of his
head off pull this thing out
put his head back together he wakes up
at like
two in the morning off his head on
morphine or whatever he's you know
he's just off his head there's a nurse
at the end of the bed and he wakes and
goes
oh hi my name's fred i'm a falconer
and then he turns to me and phillip and
he says dad can i get a falcon
and i said fred you can have whatever
you want
wow so a couple of weeks goes by we
don't know what this thing is what is
this brain tumor is it bad is it good
we don't know what it is the pathologies
they said oh we'll know next week it's
taken two weeks
three weeks uh you know it's august and
it's the most
horrifying experience as a parent to not
know whether your kid's gonna die or not
yeah and i'm walking into
the grocery store one day my phone rings
it's salt lake and they go look we're
gonna tell you
and i'm like because i knew the moment
they said they were going to tell me
what it was
it was and they said it's it's a
low-grade glioma it's not going to kill
him
it's you know if it grows back we'll
take it out again
and you know anyway
fred's got to get a bird i promised
so here's the thing america there's a
lot of laws
i say to my american buddies you've got
a lot of laws protecting your freedom
right so in our falcons yeah and
actually you know what
great so you should have a lot of laws
protecting your falcons
so fred has allowed like a couple of
different birds there's lots of falcons
and hawks and the eagles and everything
in the states but he's really only
allowed a couple of them because he's a
he's a novice yeah you have to go
through stages you have to exams you
have to
you know what i mean so fred is
basically allowed red-tailed hawk where
we live
okay so he has to we we build him this
muse this avery his friend roger who's a
master falconer and
mentors fred um
fred has to go and catch a red-tailed
hawk once he's
built the avery you just don't buy one
you don't go down to the pet store and
buy a red tail no this is where i get
this is where the
story gets really cool okay he can catch
a wild red tail but it has to have been
born that year
right it's called a passage bird it's
migrating
south you catch it in the fall
it's it's first year it's not an adult
it's never bred before
these are the rules this is these are
the rules okay if you catch an adult you
have to let it go
okay so to catch one you get some mice
from the
mouse store and you put them in a thing
called the belshakry which is this
trap and you put them in a tank so the
bird can't get them but the bird flies
down trying to get so you basically
drive around until you see a bird
you put this trap thing down it's got
these mice the bird flies in it gets its
leg caught in a leg
snare thing it doesn't injure it or
damage it and then you run out and you
pick the bird up and then
that's your bird you then train from
from wild okay so fred says to me
oh dad i want a female dark morph red
tail
right it's not really you want a female
dark wolf passage red so it's gotta be
born that yeah it's gonna be a dark one
there's
light normal red tails and dark red has
like three different color morphs
and he wants a female yeah of course you
do so they go
buy some mice him and his mom the next
day we're gonna trap this bird for him
and it's gonna be his bird for life blah
blah blah
next day the neighbor phones up she says
oh you got an eagle stuck in your fence
and fred goes running up the garden is
i always lose it and on the ground is a
dark morph
female passive red town he picks it up
that's his bird wow he doesn't even
catch it one day he just
goes up the garden there's a bird on the
ground that's flown into our garden
fence
and he just and it's exactly what and he
just picks it up that's it but
how cool is that well charlie hamilton
james thank you very much
thank you
to see some of charlie's photographs
including his national geographic
stories on kingfishers
otters and vultures check out the links
in our show notes
they're right there in your podcast app
you can also find his photographs on our
instagram feed
at nat geo
[Music]
overheard at national geographic is
produced by laura sim
brian gutierrez jacob pinter carla wills
and alana strauss our senior editor is
eli
chin this episode was edited by robert
moleski
our executive producer of audio is duvar
ardellon
our fact checkers are michelle harris
robin palmer and julie beer
our copy editor is amy kulzak hansdale
sue
sound designed this episode and composed
our theme music
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
susan goldberg is national geographic's
editorial director
and i'm your host peter gwynne thanks
for listening
and see y'all next time
[Music]
you